it's weird right because um i and i saw
i read about this and it's called a
maximizer and a satisfier right
some people will take the first option
that satisfies them yeah they're okay
with that
there are other people who maximize the
[ __ ] out of everything
yeah and i don't know what happened but
somewhere around the age of
18 to 20 i swapped from being a
maximizer and
literally everything in my life yeah to
just being satisfied yeah and like i
remember when i was buying a vacuum for
the first time
holy [ __ ] dude i like spreadsheets on
spreadsheets
i was like yo but the suction power of
this one is 50 watts extra and
[ __ ] this is bristles extra firm ones
then but the reviews of this one
oh my you know what i mean like yeah
yeah we get stressed out about
everything yeah i haven't that happened
with youtube in the start but
somewhere along the line i just stopped
giving a [ __ ] about everything yeah and
i'm i'm like now you know even when i i
remember i used to book hotels i used to
like i would
i would my god i would search every
hotel like a 10 mile radius
yeah i would have a spreadsheet and i
just got to the point where i realized
i don't think this matters i don't think
i need to do this yeah
and now i just take the first thing that
makes me remotely happy yeah i mean it's
it's just kind of like decision fatigue
right yeah yeah yeah
like there's only so many decisions that
you can make in a day and
there are some points when i'm exactly
the same especially when i'm like
booking a holiday or finding like
even just like choosing what you want to
eat today yeah i
i'd say the only thing i still do it in
my life is for video games like i still
do that for video games but
everything else uh even youtube i just
do what i do and i'm satisfied with that
like i um i check the analytics i
you know like roughly but i don't go
deep into them like i just see
okay you're not like oh my god i'm i'm
down one percent from yesterday
yeah if i gain less subscribers than the
previous day i don't care i'm like i'm
still gaining subscribers
yeah exactly i actually found like a
huge problem for me recently is that
i've
i've found it really hard just to get
into new anime and games
just because like there's so much choice
and i don't know i have this thing where
i'm so
scared of wasting my time see that thing
you need to let go like i had that i had
that yeah i just i just stopped giving a
[ __ ] because like recently okay so i've
the the most recent anime i finished was
one that i had last season it was called
sing yesterday for me and like the first
the first beginning of that was [ __ ]
great i was like i'm good this is gonna
be a show
this is like anime with the season kind
of territory and then i watched it
and the first half was great and then
the second half was just kind of like
nothing's really happening and then it
ended and then it just
it just kind of just ended very fast it
was obviously like a very
rushed ending it was like the most seven
out of ten
overall i remember your tweet where you
were like guys
watching yesterday for me anime of the
season
take it from me the anime zone
the one like yes you have that story
and i like i just i remember i finished
it and i knew
this was an anime i'm going to forget in
like a month
i'm like that's okay is it though i
think it's okay because the way i see
things right is like no matter what
happens
if i get something i can talk about
that's a win like you you brought it up
it's all about the experience you had
something
you you
[Laughter]
if i have something that i can take away
like that that's painfully mediocre
something i could talk about i can't be
mad but imagine if i didn't have a
podcast where i could just talk
talk about talk about yourself you could
talk about it to your friends right you
could have said
this if it had been good would you have
been happy yes no you wouldn't have
you'd have been you'd have been like
satisfied with the choice you made you
wouldn't have been happy
i didn't know i would like because i
know
he was a good animator because he wanted
it to be an amazing anime and if it
lived up to his expectations he'd be
like
good he wouldn't be like oh my god yes
no i mean like
i mean i know this guy no no i would be
happy [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you i i would be happy i'm happy
watching good anime
just don't show me like okay like okay
the one thing that's even worse than
being a bad anime
is just being a meh anime like like like
i remember like when i finished domestic
girlfriend like the manga okay
so i finished it like a few weeks go
back to this again we're going back to
domestic
girl finds a way to bring it back he
always finds a [ __ ] word
ex-girlfriend that he just can't like i
i can't let her go but
like it was an awful ending like it was
it was
absolutely like one of one of the worst
endings to like a harem
this is the worst trade deal
like okay just just just just imagine it
right okay this is this is this is what
it was like okay imagine
okay it's it's the world cup final okay
okay
okay no okay in terms of like which girl
is going to win
so it's the world cup final you're in
the 90th minute it's in stoppage time
you're like 10 one up okay and then for
no like the other team is like
completely incapacitated
and then for no reason you decide to
play golden goal and then score an own
goal
that was the ending of domestic
girlfriends well that's that's fun
don't talk about that no no no
but that but that's the thing right is
that because it was so bad
i had a great time like experiencing
just
just the dumpster fire and like the
nuclear fallout that it caused that's
fun right yeah
like i had more fun with i'm gonna
remember domestic girlfriend for way way
[ __ ] longer
right than sing yesterday for me because
what i'm so scared of is just
i'm gonna watch a show and i'm gonna be
like i'm gonna and i'm gonna forget the
show within a month but that happens a
lot
it does you know like as somebody who
watches
so many [ __ ] documentaries like i
watch a lot of documentaries it's
probably
the only thing i really watch on netflix
right kind of come to accept that real
life
doesn't have good enemies unfortunately
like life just
doesn't it just kind of ends it just
doesn't have good endings right
like you know and the if you if you make
documentaries about people who are still
alive
sometimes they keep doing [ __ ] after the
documentary comes out yeah that's like
it's not a complete documentary
right but i don't know i just kind of
get ex like
like satisfied with what i get if it's a
good journey yeah and
if it's a met ending that's something i
would talk about that's the way i see it
like and it's a shitty documentary great
i have something to talk about it's a
good documentary
cool i can talk about it like i've just
come to accept that
life just doesn't have good endings it
rarely lives up to the first day but
that on a t-shirt
yeah you know like give one tiger king
first pop is way better than the last
part
come on yeah of course you know what i
mean like it's
i don't know i just come to accept that
it was good when it was good and i'm not
gonna get too fussed about it
yeah i mean it's it that's the whole
thing right it's it's just this idea of
like you know
nothing in life is pointless like you'll
always find a way to utilize that in
some way and
no matter how [ __ ] mediocre a show is
you're gonna you're gonna use it
somewhere
even if you're not even aware of it
right like yeah
i realize how [ __ ] weird i am right
now because i just don't like story and
video games but i'm happy with mediocre
stories
you'll love a lot of visuals
i i mean i don't know it's hard it's
this this is like a debate that i'm
trying to come to terms with myself
yeah is it okay to watch something media
but is it okay to play something for the
story yeah exactly
no everyone's like did you play last of
us no
it's all story but you get to shoot
things in it no
there's no skill involved you know
there's no there's nothing i can master
i love halo and i love playing the uh
like legendary roots alone where like
it's [ __ ] impossible the [ __ ] driving
up the wall
like every 12 year old i didn't talk to
in school yeah probably
i think we wouldn't get on instagram if
we went to the same school i would be
like
[ __ ] that place halo
legendary what a wanker yeah i love that
[ __ ] jesus christ
no but so yeah is there is there
anything else you guys want to talk
about for this podcast bottom line
i don't think conor is ever going to get
into visual novels and that and that's
no that's
how it is the more i talk to him the
more i'm like yeah original novel
you know it's the natto of anime
i feel like you're either genetically
supposed what's the word like you're
gonna you're more likely to like it
what's the word there's a word for i'm
[ __ ]
supposed or something it's something
along those lines it's not that word
yeah i feel like we're a bit drunk right
i feel like you're either going to like
visual novels or you're not and you and
you know
if if someone explains a visual novel
too you're going to be like
don't think that yeah yeah yeah i just i
don't know but like i've never met
someone who just doesn't like story
period yeah that's that's a lot
like like like if you don't like story
in games period then i'm like
i like story not in video games get out
of my video games
bro force amazing game metal slug
amazing game
no stories in those games that's what we
need doing are you telling me you never
looked up the law
of metal slug i i have played
too many hours of metal slug love that
game to death i have no idea if there's
a story
is there a story in metals apparently
there is [ __ ] off no there is
yeah there's apparently the story doom
20 uh the new doom i [ __ ] loved but i
was like wait
wait there's cutscenes no
no no no no would you not like care
about something like world building for
example yeah but you can do that through
gameplay
yeah but like yeah but it's not as
effective yeah in my opinion
there's like there's so many okay
there's so many games that try to
do what we're building through right you
play the new dooms you know exactly what
the world is about
just from but aren't aren't you like
actually interested
in the world no
and there's your shoulders are you
interested in this how the world
got that way i say that right but every
time i hear a piece of like league of
legends law i'm like that's cool
that's cool and i actually i'd watch the
league of legends anime yeah
but i don't want to watch league of
legends cut scenes in game imagine you
have to watch cut scenes in league of
legends
connor has like two modes in his brain
yeah and there's like no in between
there's like it's just like shut off
brain um like
abs absolutely anime yeah it's it's it
could be [ __ ] you just like absorb it
or it's like monkey brain mode engage
i am the greatest primate in this group
it's like on or off right like i can sit
there and watch like
any anime or whatever you need me to
watch i could sit there and watch it all
day and be like
okay i know what i'm getting into but
when it's games get that [ __ ] out of
here
get that [ __ ] off of me jesus christ
i literally like i love watching tyler1
like live streams
yeah because i feel like he embodies
he's the definition of monkey brain
i love tai lawan as a streamer because
he literally embodies
like not only physically how like i
imagined my gamer side to be
but like watching him play the last of
us was so funny because he was just like
what is this story get this [ __ ] away
from me and i was like i love it i love
it it's so fun
and he's just such a like gigger chad
brain gamer it's so fun to watch him
he's my favorite streamer just because
like i i relate to him oh my god oh god
i guess though you guys can let us know
in the comments below if there is any
visual novel that
you think connor's monkey brain can
handle i've lost
all hope we can't we can't convince them
so maybe you guys can hold on yeah okay
you know what before we finish this
people were like yeah i i've beat fire i
was like oh yeah me too
and they were like oh did you play all
the roots i'm like why would i play all
the rooms
i remember talking to you about this i'm
like that that hurts me
i'm like why would i play all the roots
well you play blue lines right i play
blue lines which i
you know after i heard about all the
other roots i'm like so i played the
right one
no no no no no no no no there's no right
one yeah that's just one of three yeah
mine sounded like the most so we're
going back into fate now
oh no